yeah
hello there it's PS plus time again the
mid-month update that adds more games to
the game catalog for extra and premium
subscribers sprinkled with a few more
offerings solely for the premium Bunch
all these games will be available from
Tuesday November 15th and there's 25 to
get through so let's crack on Kingdom
Heart kicks off the update the amazing
jrpg is here and it's so much more than
one game it's essentially nine games as
Sora and his enormous keyblade team up
with Donald and Goofy and visit Disney
Worlds from all the movies you grew up
with right up to the latest Disney house
to offer Kingdom Hearts HD 1.5 and 2.5
remix present us with a reforged form of
the original four games and their
spin-offs Kingdom Hearts HD 2.8 adds
another three experiences on top of that
culminating with Kingdom Hearts 3 which
ends the story The Kingdom Hearts naming
conventions are insane to say the least
gameplay wise the combat system revolves
around sora's transforming keyblades
going from a close-up melee bash vest to
dual wielding guns from distance to
summoning Disneyland rides straight out
of real life the locations and
interactions with Disney characters are
the real wow factor revisiting Andy's
room to see the cast of Toy Story or
traveling to the Frozen Outdoors to see
Elsa never gets old there's a few
hundred hours of gameplay and story to
get into here so be careful you may
become addicted and if you do you'll end
up playing another game added this month
Melody of memory a freaking action
rhythm game set in the world of Kingdom
Hearts if that's too cartoony for you
then welcome the return of the greatest
RPG ever made the Elder Scrolls 5 Skyrim
you probably have bought this on
multiple platforms yet here it is again
this time it's the special edition on
both PS4 and PS5 learn to shout in
gibberish and throw your enemies with
your voice you are the doverkin the
special edition brings remastered
Graphics effects lighting depth of field
reflections so it's the best looking
Skyrim ever which is pretty good for a
game which originally came out 11 years
ago the special edition is also crammed
with all the DLC ever made and there's
mod 2 to give the game even more life if
you have the platinum trophy already you
must Flex in the comments below it's law
next up is another game previously on PS
plus odd World Soul storm but this time
it's the enhanced Edition the
side-scrolling 2.5 D platformer in which
we play as Abe a slave attempting to
escape his captors and he tries to bring
along his fella madokans too madokans
madokans madokans anyway Soul storm adds
looting and crafting to the base
mechanics and also a pacifist move to
apprehend enemies without unaliving them
some people love this game some dislike
it and the reviews reflect that it's
either a 6 or an 8 out of 10 but you'll
have to play to figure out which one
since Sony's partnership with Ubisoft
it's now commonplace to see their games
added each month and yep here we go
again three more Ubisoft games all Tom
Clancy too the competitor of Juggernaut
Rainbow Six Siege is the least casual
thing on the list you play as a highly
trained military operative and must
either trench in or remove another team
of operatives when online playing with
real people aim assist is removed and a
single bullet to the head and your part
in the round it can be extremely
difficult to go up against players who
have been playing for years because they
already know the best angles to sit and
wait for you but for those who want to
challenge it is great though I highly
recommend playing with friends if you
choose to the division 2 is next up and
brings in RPG elements as a ravaged
Washington DC needs liberating and it's
up to you to do it encountering many
factions with specific weaponry and
tactics and by eliminating those they
drop loot which we then use to upgrade
our own equipment and as that number
goes up the more areas become open until
we fight the final boss the online
component allows for friends and
teammates to join you and should you
enter the dark Zone be prepared for a
mixture of PVP and PV e combat with the
AI and then combat with real players who
will try and steal all the loot you've
been Gathering can you escape with that
weapon you've been hunting for for four
hours probably not and Tom Clancy's
final offering this month is Ghost Recon
breakpoint imagine mixing the last two
games together and that is breakpoint we
are an elite Spec Ops Team sent to
another country to free it from Evil
dictators alongside AI or real players
you'll travel to the right place you'll
Recon The Zone you'll decide a plan
meticulously and you're slowly and
precisely take out everyone who's a
threat or if you're like me and my
friends we'll all loudly run in and
shoot everything that moves whilst
talking about the latest Netflix show
we're watching you do you but for
certain breakpoint is far more fun with
friends how about a Sci-Fi shooting game
check out chorus and Intergalactic space
shooter it plays out like an alternative
Star Wars Universe without spoiling
anything we play as Nara one of the
greatest Pilots to ever live and by the
end of the game you'll think you'll know
her full story yet there is a Twist
worthy of Star Wars itself gameplay is
all about Space Battles It's like Star
Fox with upgrades those upgrades are the
main Loop to keep you going back into
fights a new Blaster with more range a
new speed Thruster may be or you could
save your credits for a crystal reactor
IGN gave chorus an 8 out of 10. if
you've had enough shooty shooty bang
bang for the month take a look at what
remains of Edith Finch one of the first
walking simulators dedicated to
investigative storytelling a curse has
taken a family away and we need to
uncover how it happened and maybe how it
can be undone finding secret moments
hidden passages and how their life was
ended it's a short two-hour game with
profound moments and it's definitely
worth your time oh there are two Earth
Defense Force games added this month
World brother and iron rain a third
person shooter that is loved in Japan
one is most definitely aimed at children
and the other one is a little bit more
mature we play as a simple soldier in
the military when aliens attack our job
is simple protect Japan protect the
Earth check this out Oni chanbara origin
is this month's hack and slash outing
where we play as an overly sexualized
zombie hunter with some of the greatest
Katana moves you'll see this year the
combat is way more addicting than I
expected with combolds and the ability
to extend them oh and the boss fights
they are low-key amazing and they'll
challenge your ability to stop button
bashing and become more controlled damn
it I really do like this game I just
can't say the title Oni chanbara origin
and finally on PS plus extra this month
the gardens between a puzzle game about
memories we play as Arena and friend as
we cross our Islands made of memories
well we don't actually play as them we
play as the island itself and lead them
through by controlling time it's almost
like a Spot the Difference game in some
sections As Time Changes items change
the puzzles are surprisingly complex
late in the game for a game of this size
at around 3 hours in length it's a good
way to break up any of the bigger games
you're playing this month right onto PS
Plus premium we go we've been eating
poorly on this tier so far but this
could be the start of a change five
games will be added and they are all
Ratchet and Clank it's the 20th
anniversary of the Ratchet and Clank
series and to commemorate it the ogps3
ratcheting Clank is added that is Then
followed up with two sequels with great
names going commando and up Your Arsenal
and then two more with standard names
deadlocked and tools of Destruction as
far as an action platformer goes Ratchet
and Clank is a stellar experience with
all five games averaging a review score
of over 80. the highest is up Your
Arsenal hitting 91 a Metacritic and the
lowest is 2006's deadlock which got 81
out of 100 so there you have it 25
experiences added to PS plus this update
including nine Kingdom Hearts I hope you
like Kingdom Hearts games I'm Adam
you're awesome it's been a pleasure I'll
see you next time